hi in this video I will be talking about
making Drosophila mutant using P element
mutagenesis before understanding how we
create the mutant we should understand
why we create the mutant so in my
earlier videos I talked about how we can
create a knockdown or overexpression
using our RNA AI but RNA AI has a
problem RNA I could be off targeted I
mean RNA I could lead to opt off
targeted effects so that is why if we
get some phenotype in RNA AI then we
need to make a mutant and if this mutant
also show similar type of phenotype then
we are confident about our decision so
that is why we need to create Drosophila
mutant using P element mutagenesis so
let's jump into what is P element so P
element basically is a transposon so you
can see this is the basic structure of a
P element and transposon means jumping
genes so in this schematic you can see P
element has a particular region which
code for a particular gene and you can
see inside of it there is a sequence
which codes for an enzyme which is known
as transposes and these transposes would
actually help this p element to jump
from one location to another location
another important feature of these P
elements are it has terminal inverted
repeats and then if we look into the
mechanism what happens in the normal
cases then we could understand how we
could use this system and create in
order to create mutagenesis so in normal
conditions let's say this is a p element
sitting over here in this genomic
location so it has its own gene sequence
and it has its own transpose a sequence
it can give rise to transposes so this
transpose is represented here as green
would actually help this red transposon
to hop and this red transposon would
actually jump from that location it
would break from that location and it
would nucleophilically attack another
portion of the chromosome another G
maybe another gene represented here in
blue so after it attacked so these red
transposon disrupt that particular gene
and get inserted into that location so
this is the basic mechanism of P element
mutagen P element properties and how the
P element can hop and get inserted into
our new genomic location but it is very
important to understand that whatever a
technique we are using in Drosophila
it's little bit different from the
real-time scenario so this particular
technique is known as imprecise excision
so in the earlier condition we see that
this p element is able to make
transposes but here our p element which
is sitting near a gene gene of interest
and the gene that we want to mute it is
actually transpose is deficient I mean
it can't produce its own transpose is so
and that is why it needs help from other
sources which can produce transposons
and so let's jump into a flight cross so
here is our simplistic cross so these
cross doesn't represent the real
real-time scenario but it's conceptually
correct so I would make a video on the
detailed cross and how these works but
the basic concept is one side you have
to have a P element line and on the
other hand side you have to have a
transposes line because remember in the
P element line whatever P elements you
have which is sitting near a gene is
defective that means it can produce its
transposes so that is why this p element
line need the help of these Delta
a transposes line it helps this P
element line requires a help from other
transposes in order to jump so in the
right hand side you can see this fly it
has a delta 2 3 tongue transposes and
why delta 2 3 because what about
transpose is this fly have it's actually
defective so now the whole bottom line
is our p element is defective our
transposes is defective so that is why
if we get back into our diagram what we
would see that when when the excision is
happening its imprecise so you can see
this a delta 2 3 transpose which
represented as green would actually cut
these red transpose on and it would help
it to jump but as these delta 2 3
transpose is is defective
this cleavage may not be precise it's
very important to understand this
cleavage may not be precise that means
imprecise excision could lead to a
portion of a portion of gene to be
jumped and to be hopped out of its own
location so you can see here is a whole
gene in orange so this orange the gene
is preceded by this particular p element
of interest and if we we are able to
jump this p element with these
particular Delta 2 3 transposes then
what we would find that a portion of the
gene may be jump along with this
particular transposon but this is a
chance factor maybe in one condition
it could jump along with the gene maybe
in one condition the excision is precise
so that is why in the f1 generation when
you establish the p element mobilized
line
you have to do a mass cross and then
from this P element lines maybe 400 or
500 lines you have to screen you have to
screen and find your mutant you have to
fish out of all these lines and you have
to find your mutant so in order to do so
you can perform a PCR based screening so
you would expect that a portion of your
gene is actually removed with that
particular P element so your gene would
be now truncated but you don't know
where the break occurs that is why you
have to perform
you have to use a series of reverse
primer but only one single forward
primer in order to do a PCR screen and
let's say you get a band which is
truncated and which is a downward so you
may infer that there is a deletion and
this particular band is corresponding to
your mute your mutant and then you have
to characterize that and sequence that
in order to confirm the mutation and
then also you have to check for the
phenotype you can see you have to do all
this experiment with respect to a
control and if you want to learn more
about how these PCR screening works then
I would make a different video on that
but for now this concept would
illustrate a basic mechanism how these P
element mutagenesis system could be used
to produce Drosophila mutant and the
whole process is actually imprecise
excision that means excision of the P
element which is quite imprecise and it
would take a portion of a chunk of the
gene with along with it and thus
creating a deletion mutation so if you
liked my video and give it a quick
thumbs up and don't forget to leave your
comments below and please subscribe to
get more such videos thank you